bonheur c'est un mec qui passe devant le
juge lui dit écoutez monsieur quels sont
les faits qui vous sont reprochés et dit
Monsieur j'ai fait mes courses de Noël
un peu trop tôt et des bas c'est pas
vrai par la loi ça mais qu'est-ce que
vous avez payé qu'est-ce que vous
appelez un peu trop tôt dis bah le
magasin il était fermé
elle est sympa elle est partie plus
rapide que ton bide toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaussures
un peu réussi tout va bien je suis bien
dans ma tête je suis bien dans ma peau
et j'ai des belles chaussures mais où
est-ce que tu les as acheté ben écoute
on est allé en safari avec ma femme on a
tiré sur un sur un crocodile on l'a
retourné et les chaussures c'est génial
donc on y va deux ans après il retourne
on retrouve son pote et lui dit et alors
je ne comprends pas j'ai fait comme tu
m'as dit je suis allé dans un safari je
suis j'ai pris un fusée j'ai tiré sur le
crocodile je l'ai retourné n'avait pas
de chaussures
[Applaudissements]
je vous expliquerai pourquoi oui j'ai
entendu vous êtes beaux quand même dans
les blagues
je vous raconte la vie
tu sais moi la mienne elle a des cuisses
de grenouilles alors je la saute
la mienne elle a une culotte de cheval
alors je la monte
hôpital 3e qui dit mais attends la
mienne elle a rien à voir elle a un cul
d'éléphant alors je la trompe
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
moi j'ai rien compris comme d'habitude
la police
donc ouais c'est deux blondes qui sont
devant la Tour Eiffel elles sont comme
ça
un truc de ouf
d'ascenseur on est obligé de monter à
pied c'est un truc de ouf moi et donc
c'est génial c'est un truc de ouf il y a
un mec qui arrive
English non surtout pas quand tu vas
pas parler italien
Panzani ça va quoi
ah non pas de German non non pas Duche
rien du tout jamais de douche le matin
le soir jamais
rien rien merci casse-toi à côté faire
ça serait peut-être pas mal qu'on
apprenne quand même à parler des langues
étrangères ah ben tu vois lui il en
parle 4 ça lui sert à rien du tout
c'est la tête c'est l'interprétation
aussi tu vois c'est la comédie c'est la
comédie Jean-Marie il me regarde il a
envie de me dire quelque chose
j'ai simplement envie de dire que c'est
un jeune homme de 18 ans 18 ans c'est
quand même l'âge quoi il décide tant pis
de franchir le Rubicon comme on dit il
va aller voir une professionnelle pour
se déniéser comme disait ma grand-mère
tu vois il est un petit peu ému en train
de se déshabiller dans la chambre et il
lui dit à la fille est-ce que ça vous
dérange madame si je vous appelle Eve
et m'a dit non je m'en branle un petit
peu mais pourquoi ben dis parce que vous
allez être ma première femme donc j'ai
envie de vous appeler Eve a dit ouais
comme tu veux et après je dis et moi je
peux t'appeler Peugeot
est-ce que tu es mon 38e client
[Applaudissements]
e
à son pote qui est d'origine japonaise
il rend visite à l'hôpital et il vient
le voir il dit qu'on a grandi ensemble
on est des potes et d'un coup le mec qui
sert son pote japonais le cerf fort
optimis et le japonais fait
donc lui il a un peu dégoûté bon il
appelle il y a la mer du du japonais sa
petite amie qui vient et du côté voilà
votre votre fils et votre mari il est
mort mais il a une dernière volonté mais
je comprends pas le japonais moi il dit
c'est quoi la dernière volonté il a dit
et là il y a la mer est tombé dans les
pommes il dit mais pourquoi il est tombé
dans les pommes ça veut dire lâche-moi
je suis en train d'étouffer
c'est un ancien préretraite mais il veut
continuer à travailler dans une boutique
bien gominée cosy mais il dit bonjour
monsieur l'homme je peux parler au
patron s'il vous plaît oui c'est moi
bonjour monsieur enchanté je m'appelle
Gérard Delmas numéro 1 des ventes en
France numéro en vendeur commercial je
vends tout ce que vous voulez dit non
mais monsieur on recherche pas de
vendeur monsieur s'il vous plaît je
m'appelle Gérard Delmas numéro 1 des
vendeur en France Laurent commercial je
suis meilleur pour moi bon bah ok du
sort important il dit voilà si vous
arrivez à vendre ça bravo la journée
passe il commence à vendre
il y a pas un truc qui a été vendu le
vendeur qu'est-ce qui se comment vous
appelez déjà Gérard Delmas numéro 2 des
vendeur en France je pensais que vous
avez du numéro 1 je suis énorme du 7
merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du boulot il a il a 100 km à faire il y
a c'est dans une petite dans une petite
campagne et puis tout à coup bah il
crève il pleut bien sûr il est 22h il
pleut il sort il se dit [ __ ] saoule
quoi il ouvre son truc machin oh [ __ ]
pas de crise oh il est dégoûté il pleut
il y a personne ni noir il dit [ __ ] je
vais marcher donc il ferme sa voiture il
commence à marcher et puis il voit un
panneau prochain village 42 km et il
marche il dit mais c'est [ __ ] c'est
ils vont me laisser comme une merde sur
le bord de la route personne va m'aider
ils vont pas me soutenir j'ai pas de
portable j'ai pas de truc je suis
dégoûté et il marche et il se monte la
tête et dégoûté parce que il arrive au
village il est dit mais je vais arriver
au village je vais taper à 22h les gens
jamais ils vont m'ouvrir ils vont rester
chez eux en train de bouffer que leurs
enfants ses petits connards ils ont là
avec leur soupe jamais ils vont m'ouvrir
ils vont rester porte close et moi je
vais marcher que je vais rentrer chez
moi il sera 5h du matin et il marche et
il marche et il marche et il se monte la
tête et il est hystérique et enfin il
arrive au village il tape comme ça il y
a un mec qui ouvre la fenêtre il dit
c'est pourquoi donc tu peux te le [ __ ]
dans le cul
il peut souvent dans les bagues de
chaussures là
elle est très bien c'est un glace dans
un taxi le taxi il y a une bonne sœur
qui est sur la banquette arrière et le
taxi ne peut pas dévisser ses yeux du
rétroviseur regarde comme ça TOI au
point que la bonne sœur derrière qui est
très jolie très beaux yeux et tout et
lui dit Monsieur arrêtez de regarder
dans le rétro à finir par avoir un
accident tu vois tu vois même mais il
dit je peux pas vous êtes tellement
jolie et pour tout vous dire ma sœur mon
fantasme à moi c'est un jour d'embrasser
sur la bouche
une bonne soeur et savais que ça allait
dévié
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi pas faudrait remplir évidemment
trois conditions ainsi que d'abord vous
soyez chrétiens bien sûr que vous ne
soyez pas marié que vous soyez donc
célibataire c'est très très important et
le mec il dit mais il dit c'est bon moi
je suis je suis pas marié je suis
complètement célibataire je suis libre
il y a aucun souci et la bonne chose dit
bon ben allez
gardez vous là il se gare à peine il est
garé la bonne sœur à lui saute dessus à
lui roule une gamelle comme jamais tu
vois allumer la langue dans les trous de
nez et tout à lui faire heureusement que
c'était pas moi
elle lui fait un tour de de Grand 8 tu
vois absolument incroyable ça remet ça
manquait le taxi redémarre puis tout
d'un coup il se met
à sangloter tu vois et elle lui dit pour
vous vous pleurez que ça et dit même ce
que je suis un sale menteur d'abord je
suis juif je ne suis pas
catholique j'ai trompé ma femme enfin
j'ai je suis un très gros pêcheur la
bonne sœur a dit c'est pas grave
regardez moi je m'appelle Gérard et je
vais au carnaval
[Applaudissements]